[Music]
we begin the program with breaking news
that the British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson has been moved to intensive care
inside a London hospital after his
covered 19 symptoms worsened Johnson was
admitted to hospital on Sunday night and
had been undergoing tests after
suffering persistent symptoms for more
than 10 days earlier on Monday the
government had said Boris Johnson was in
good spirits and still in charge but
Downing Street now says Foreign
Secretary Dominic Robb has been asked to
deputize but improper joins me now live
from London via Skype and Nadeem I think
it was only a few days ago I think
Thursday evening when we saw some images
of the Prime Minister he stepped outside
briefly to applaud workers of the
National Health System that was Thursday
it's now Monday and it seems an
incredibly quick deterioration what else
do we know that's right Barbara when he
did appear in down the street on
Thursday evening for that applause for
health and care workers he didn't look
her well man at all lots of people
commented on that but it's not a
surprising development for somebody who
has coronavirus who has covered 19 as he
did and went into isolation over ten
days ago for things to change fairly
quickly I mean in terms of a number of
days that's not a surprising development
that he was admitted to some Thomas's
Hospital on the south bank of the River
Thames on Sunday evening local time we
were told that was for precaution as a
precautionary step and he'd be receiving
routine checks it's understood that
those checks partly had to do with any
breathing difficulties and that was also
because he was still suffering symptoms
of cupboard 19 including a high
temperature and a persistent cough one
of the the well known symptoms is a dry
cough now on Monday of course he didn't
share the cabinet meeting for the first
time since he was in isolation he'd been
doing it by a video leak Dominic robbed
the Foreign Secretary did then mr. Rob
appeared at this press briefing
a few hours ago now saying that Boris
Johnson was in good spirits and in fact
Boris Johnson himself had tweeted as
much that he was fine basically and mr.
roffe's said under repeated questioning
from reporters who were questioning why
Boris Johnson was continuing to work if
it was unwell enough to be in hospital
mr. robb said he continues to take
advice from his doctors but that he
continues to run things he continues to
head the government and to receive
regular updates will now this surprise
news that on at about 7:00 p.m. local
time just a couple of hours ago from 10
Downing Street themselves saying that he
was moved to the intensive care unit in
that hospital in case he needed a
ventilator now the local press are also
reporting a bit more detail saying that
in fact in the course of the afternoon
he started to experience breathing
difficulties and had to be administered
oxygen that doesn't mean he was using a
ventilator but it does mean that it had
become more serious that much is clear
Barbara so and obviously there's a lot
that we don't know right now in the deme
but from what we do understand it
doesn't seem that he's been intubated
quite yet
Nadeem can you hear me I think we've
lost the connection to Nadine Barbara
joining us from London well Nadeem thank
you for that and of course we'll bring
you more developments on the condition
of Boris Johnson the British prime prime
minister who has been taken to intensive
care a few hours ago now the news broke
in the past half hour or so and we will
bring you more developments as we get
them here in the newsroom